hello everyone and welcome to today's
web seminar the health economic value of
laboratory information and hepatitis C
screening programs I am Megan Paschal of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Abbott to learn more visit
corelaboratory.abit.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Paul ulicher PhD senior director medical
Affairs Health economics and outcome
research at core diagnostic Diagnostics
Abbott Dr
ulicher you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much for inviting me to
talk about this very important and
highly interesting topic I would like to
talk about
some important aspects of hcv screening
programs and discuss some health
economic implications of
um of this
so let's talk first about some kind of
you know Global epidemiologics and both
based on the latest estimates about 57
million people currently live with
active hepatitis C infection and this
equals a kind of a global prevalence of
0.7 well as you can see here on the map
so the prevalence certainly varies
dramatically between countries from less
than 0.5 percent to up to up to more
than five percent in the total
population in some areas well there are
some countries that carry basically 50
of the global burden such as China
Pakistan India Russia and also the US
and apparently approximately sorry about
75 percent of infected persons really
develop persistent bureemia and almost
half of the of all infected patients
develop serious liver damage during
their lifetime
so that makes chronic hepatitis C really
the leading cause of end-stage liver
disease liver cancer and liver
transplantation
what has been reported that the number
of active infections decreased over the
last five years as you also can see here
on the slide but even if hcv prevalence
reached a Peak at around the the the
turn of the Millennium the
disease-related healthcare costs really
caused by the long-term consequences is
estimated to increase for more than 30
years after the peak in prevalence and
this is the period we are moving towards
now
so
um into
2016 The Who
defined specific targets to really
eliminate hepatitis C and 80 decline in
hcv incidence and has 65 reduction in
hcv related mortality by 2030 and that
requires that more than 90 percent of
infected people need to be diagnosed and
and need to be treated
so and based on the latest numbers
latest report less than a quarter
currently of less than a quarter of
active infections had been diagnosed
currently and only about one percent
initiated treatment in 2020 so there is
still an urgent need to detect and treat
hepatitis C in fact patients
so to stress this again the enormous
burden of hepatitis C has been reported
for many years and in many many papers
and with the Advent of Highly efficient
drugs it has changed into a more
optimistic period it has been reported
that
successfully diagnosing and treating
patients with active hepatitis C would
eliminate around 95 percent of the
disease within 15 years
so detection and treatment is key really
this puts the spot
on the timely identification of active
infections and hcv screening programs
well there are many ideas and programs
and many of this will proved to be cost
effective in numerous cases but still
many issues and challenges as solved
and the the the issues really became
apparent by
by
illustrating the so-called Cascade of
care from diagnosis to cure
so efforts really to identify and Link
hcv infected patients
to care
really requires substantial resources
and some of which is wasted by
inefficiencies in the Cascade of care
just a few examples frequent issues
across countries are a high number of
people that are under diagnosed and
unaware of infection
but also a very low proportion of
infected
subjects that um get access to treatment
and the first step to treatment is
confirmation of a confirmation of an
active infection and that's
traditionally done with hcv RNA which is
required to really determine people for
whom care and treatment is indicated
well
this is data for from the US but this is
not this is not uh this is not unique
dramatic losses in the Cascade of care
have also been observed and reported in
in many many other countries and as
already mentioned globally less than a
quarter of active infections have been
diagnosed and only about one percent uh
initiated treatment in 2020. and there's
of course High variation between
countries but here's some data from
Russia and again the data show that only
about 50 percent of the estimated in
fact the population get tested with
antibody
and here as you can see this is the who
Target of 90 percent
and very few get get cured or treated
right again in comparison to the who
standard or Target
so the question is what does this tell
us
I think first of all these data indicate
some critical barriers in the Cascade of
care such as access to screening
coverage access to treatment and so
forth
but this also another point that I would
like to highlight here and that is there
are barriers
in the in the cascade of testing
so barriers in the cascade of testing
really lead to incomplete diagnosis and
that is in fact a very well-known Gap
right so it's just in a just a quick
review right so screening for hcv
usually employs an antibody test for
screening and then antibody positive
cases must be confirmed for diagnosis of
an active infection
so these are data from Australia and
they and this data showed that about 60
percent
of patients are tested with antibody and
not received confirmatory testing
same in other regions in the US it has
been observed that only 55 of those
diagnosed with antibody received
confirmatory testing
and as shown on the previous Slide the
same situation appears in in Russia so
more than 60 percent of of patients get
lost in the steps in Russia
um
so
to
just to to to to summarize why this is
important because a complete picture
of of a complete picture is essential
for a meaningful and conclusive
diagnosis
so it sounds like
kind of a very simple process but it's
actually probably a bit more problematic
and so let's look a little into into
reality
foreign
ification of active infection again
employs an antibody test for screening
and all initially reactive samples
require confirmation and with a test
that is most commonly a hcv RNA test for
diagnosis of an active infection but in
many cases and that is shown here in
this chart people are required really to
go to different places such as a general
practitioner a laboratory an affected
disease specialist and they go through
several steps in order to get
diagnostically conclusive results and a
clear indication for treatment
so this kind of screening process
appears to be a logistically complicated
multi-step process with a number of
opportunities for people really to get
lost to follow up
so one could assume
that the problem or the cascade of
testing has been widely studied well
there are certainly a number of high
quality Health economic studies that
tested different strategies and ideas
from screening to a cure but if you
would take a closer look
studies usually lack information about
the cascade of testing
so the drop off within the cascade of
testing is usually not considered and
even essay on test specific assumptions
are usually rough so studies Focus
mostly on other aspects of the Cascade
of care but they ignore
the complexity of the screening Cascade
and this has also been recognized by
authors of the Canadian Health
technology assessment who concluded
that ignoring loss to follow up in
screening Cascades
overestimated
overestimated the outcomes
so
with that in mind
we were actually looking for a case
study to spend a closer look on the
cascade of testing
and in collaboration with the Russian
reference Center
we conducted a health economic study in
the setting so we sought to evaluate
whether using direct reflex strategies
with hepatitis C antigen test would have
an impact on the cascade of testing
and as we took this specific focus on
the cascade of testing we clearly
distinguished people according to their
infection status which is opposed to
most other health economic studies in
this area
so because we believe that this is an
important this is an important step to
consider the specific characteristics of
different diagnostic tools so why
because studies tell us that there are
differences in sensitivity between acute
and chronic disease States and that this
has been described for both antibody and
antigenously
this again is opposed to most other
studies and we believe that this is
really important in order to to
um
to uh
describe the process most with most
accuracy
so
um a few words about
hepatitis C antigen test
um for a couple of years hepatitis C
antigen test has been demonstrated as an
acceptable alternative to Aaron RNA for
detecting active infections
also recommended by The Who and the who
included hepatitis C antigen test in a
list of essential Diagnostics
and in addition some studies already
suggested that this test is a viable
tool for streamlining and
consolidating screening protocols
so
um
as I demonstrated
the loss in follow-up
the loss and follow-up between each step
of the screening and testing Cascade
along the process of testing is really
affecting
is crucially affecting the overall yield
so the number of complete diagnosis
strongly relies on the people and their
adherence to referrals and this was
therefore an aspect that we put into the
consideration as well
so
this this Slide
comprises the the different strategies
that were tested and compared in our
study so we compared four different
screening algorithms with a general zero
prevalence rate of what four percent and
um a rate of active infections of about
70 percent in those being positive so
just briefly the strategy one here so
that is
current practice right or was current
practice and it requires as described
multiple steps from antibody screening
through confirmation with RNA
all other strategies for using hcv
antigene in different kind of algorithms
but for the purpose of today I would
just like to
highlight oops sorry
moving back I just like to highlight
um the direct reflex strategy with um
with um
hepatitis C antigen test on antibody
positive cases
so and just by comparing these Pathways
which of course is a very rough
comparison you know this alternative
strategy requires at least two steps
less and this may have an impact on the
efficiency
and outcome of the screening Cascade
okay
[Music]
um
as I said the objective was not just to
compare
the the diagnostic performance of
different testing algorithms but also to
consider external effects potential
effects on completing the diagnosis
so adherence to the required steps is
critical right so the motivation of a
patient to follow the recommendations is
of course affected by several factors
such as the availability and the
accessibility of the next level of
service the affordability in case people
have to pay out of pocket
their
the individual knowledge about the
disease
the individual preferences of course
fearful stigma and so forth and the
perception of risk
so the perception of risk um just a
small thought example to to clarify this
so let's look on the whole process again
the perception of risk
is likely informed
um
by disclosed test results and from a
patient perspective
interpreting results is not an easy
thing right even if Guided by physicians
so what does antibody positivity mean
the adherence rate to the next stage in
the testing Cascade May differ whether
it disclosed status so the test result
is solely based on antibody positivity
or Embraces additional information such
as confirmatory tests for an active
infection
so
um
and this is why
direct reflex algorithms offer a
substantial streamlining opportunity not
just from the laborative point of view
but also in in real screening Cascades
as also suggested in many in many
studies so let's review again here the
cascade of testing in the current
setting in Russia so as you can see
about 40 percent completed
um the cascade of testing
and sixty percent get lost
so eliminating the steps between testing
stages here
eliminating the steps between the
testing stages here increase the rate of
confirmed active infections by about 70
percent and this consequently helped 60
percent more patients to complete the
process
so when we talk about cost cost wise
this table summarizes the cost per
screen subject for some of the tested
strategies well interesting to note that
the cost of the average cost uh between
strategies so the average cost per
screen subject between the strategies
were found in a very comparable range
right so well we do found however also
some statistical significance and if we
take the current practice and the um the
direct reflex approach so this would
reduce
the the
um the main cost per patient per screen
subject by about one percent
so that's only a one percent reduction
in cost but if we consider the capture
rate and calculate how much money has to
be invested in order to identify one
active infection
but the cost per diagnosed infection
appears that this one percent reduction
in costs led to a 40 reduction in the
cost per diagnosed infection
and this demonstrates a substantial
Improvement in terms of efficiency and
this perfectly makes sense right there's
any any loss in follow-up
is a wasted resource
and a much higher yield of the process
automatically improves the program
um
efficiency
okay consequently talking about value
per money right so consequently the
reflex test approach
were found to provide better value for
many compared to current practice and
this is illustrated by this cost
Effectiveness plane which really
summarizes the costs per value value
expressed as the number of diagnosed
active infections so in this chart
is highlighting two scenarios
so one and I'd like to call this the
traditional study scenario so the
traditional study scenario is ignoring
any lots and follow-up and can therefore
be considered a perfect adherent
scenario and that's this one in Gray
and the more realistic scenario
that is considering
real effects and then impaired adherence
is in is in black and I described this
in the previous in the previous slides
so
current practice here is is shown as is
a rectangle and the direct reflex
strategy is depicted by the circles and
the first thing
that that came to your your mind you
know if we first focus on the perfect
deterrence scenario as you see the
number of sorry with the mouse here the
number of diagnosed infections is
um basically the same
but costs for the direct reflex scenario
with the hcv antigene a substantially
lower
so now moving from a perfect adherent
scenario to a scenario that is
considering the adherence effects the
first thing again that stands out
is that the effect so the outcome is
significantly lower right for both
strategies and that is again in line
with what the Canadian Health technology
assessment has suggested ignoring losses
in follow-up ignoring losses in the
cascade of testing
overestimates the effect
so the other thing
that becomes a parent here is
that the direct reflex strategy so the
circles
are um
less affected
by issues in the cascade of testing
now if you compare the the circles and
and these rectangles as you can see you
know so the the fact the effect of an
impaired adherence is much larger for
current practice
so in other words
process a process with a direct reflex
strategy
is much more
robust
and the third finding here in this chart
is
that basically summarizes this right The
relap Reflex strategy with hcv antigene
is at least equally
at least equally or more effective at
lower costs than current practice
so
to summarize the findings
again first
the direct reflex approaches with a
hepatitis C antigene
provide an opportunity to streamline the
cascade of testing
and thereby reducing the potential loss
and follow-up and increasing the rate
of timely and conclusive results
and the study that I just reported this
is this study just described this and
quantifies the effects in a context in
the context of the Russian setting
the second finding
The increased number of complete
diagnosis
avoided waste of resources thereby
improving the efficiency of the program
as indicated by the substantially
reduced cost per diagnosed infection
and the increased overall lead of course
led to a significant increase in
diagnosing active infections and and
would therefore actually guide more
patients into necessary treatment
well and in summary
finally this would certainly provide
much better value for money
so there's one more thing that I would
like to bring to your attention and this
is um I think
um just putting the results into a
slightly different but I think very
important perspective
as you may know the who has also defined
dimensions of healthcare quality and of
course we tend to focus on effective
care which is to improve health outcomes
in in an evidence-based approach but
besides that
there are other extremely important
aspects that consider the structural or
organizational or
individual hurdles and I think
it would be very important from the
laboratory point of view to consider
these aspects also when we talk about
value one example
Equity Equity is an important policy
objective in almost every healthcare
system in the world and it first it
refers to healthcare that does not vary
in quality based on socioeconomic status
at the multi-step screening Cascade is
found in Russia relies on people relies
on people to invest in time and travel
productivity losses and so forth
just streamlining this testing Cascade
alleviates some of the socio-economic
impact of this just by reducing
the hurdles
so
this brings me to my conclusions
so as conclusion the study that we did
suggests that using hepatitis C antigen
test in screening algorithms would
provide cost-effective Alternatives and
the reflex The Reflex strategy with
hepatitis C antigene
or at least or is at least equally or
more effective at lower costs than
traditional practice
so the study also emphasizes the
importance to consider screening as a
multi-step diagnostic process which is a
major bottleneck to the hcv Cascade of
care and
therefore adherence
and loss to follow up
must be considered in addition to essay
performance in evaluation studies and
before making decisions so with that I
thank you so much for attending and for
listening
and hand over to Megan for the Q a
thank you
great thank you so much Dr ulicher for
your informative presentation if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question
today is does the reimbursement play a
role in the economics of adding hcv AG
to the algorithm
well this is of course a very important
question and um so the study that we did
considers a so-called Health System
perspective which basically means we're
considering cost
um
you know from what the health system or
the payers to pay and if a lab is
reimbursed for a test that's actually
caused in the eyes of a payer and that
is what we considered in our study so we
considered reimbursement in our study
and of course we as I said we evaluated
the value for money so money of course
plays a role well we run a so-called
sensitivity analysis in our study to
test the impact of and hcv antigene
reimbursement on on the test results and
what we found is that even if we triple
the reimbursement even if we triple the
reimbursement The Reflex strategy would
still be
cost effective compared to current
practice so this means the study results
are very very robust
great thank you so much our next
question is are you suggesting then that
we confirm only positive
anti-hcv tests with an hcv AG test
to confirm only positive anti-gene
nthcv test with antigene well
um
yes and that is why we what what we
found is we are talking about the
general population screening and in the
setting that we tested about 97 of all
cases were test negative
right so of course this does this does
uh include a small proportion of false
negative antibody tests but still from a
health economic perspective reflexing
all results
all results would substantially increase
costs and would hardly be cost effective
in general population screening
great thank you our next question would
the savings be even higher if we only
use hcv AG as a screening essay
would the savings be higher if we just
use hepatitis C antigen test as a
screening I say well I have to say in
general population screening running
antigen only would actually increase
costs
um but it would of course also improve
the capture rate of active infections
due to the limited sensitivity of hcv
antibody so again it really depends on
the setting but as suggested in general
population screening first line antibody
testing followed by an automatic and
direct reflex with hcv antigen on all
antibody positive cases that has been
demonstrated to be the most preferable
and most cost effective strategy
foreign that brings me to my next
question then
um is there benefit to running the hcv
AG and anti-hcv tests on every patient
sample
well
this I think is very much
related to the previous question I do
not see any benefit in a general
population screening so this again would
increase cost because most subjects 97
would be antibody negative and if we
consider a combined test result
the diagnosis would still be
inconclusive
so again as demonstrated in our study I
think I regard an automatic direct
Reflex on antibody positive cases as the
most appropriate approach in general
population screening
great it looks like we have one more
here
um what are the formal criteria to
identify candidates for testing what
should be the frequency of testing
well this is a very very interesting
well two questions not sure if I
understand the first one the former
criteria to identify candidates for
testing well there are different
criteria
um
and this varies by countries some are
some is just some some programs just
focus on on age and say test once in a
lifetime
um but there are certainly certainly
others so I think it's hard to say
um
the reason why there are differences
well
this really relies on different kind of
oh this is really very much related to
different
um prevalence uh the underlying risk in
the in the population
and so also costs I think the
recommendations that are made
are actually trying to balance these
these aspects and the the other question
the frequency of testing yeah
um as I said
um
usually we are considering a once in a
lifetime testing in a general population
but of course when we move from you know
into higher risk groups or in high risk
groups um so screening program screening
schedules are certainly different
great it looks like that brings us to
the end of our q a
um thank you so much Dr ulictor do you
have any final comments for our audience
thank you for listening and I'm happy to
take any further questions so I think
you may send some informational
questions to lab Roots right and we were
happy to to get back to you with a with
a detailed response thank you so much
great thank you again Dr Euchre for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye